you're listening to the dollop on me all
things comedy Network it's an American
history podcast each week I Dave Anthony
reading story from American history to
another guy yeah okay who's good friend
of Dave's named Gareth Reynolds who has
no idea what the topic is going to be
about get cocky well I just the standard
interest I'd be great if you just did it
the same way what you think good oh yeah
I guess I did add a little presumptuous
friends that's my call to make right
good or just a friend you know pal I
like I like you I like your friends
mouth husband like I I like your friends
like Luke and lose some of the other
guys Mike and some guys Mike Mike you
made up Mike who's Mike O'Connell Oh
your friends I know who he is but as
he's not one of my cast of characters
that you've hung out with I like your
friends I like called a boat like this
Jim Pam
Jim I'm the [ __ ] guy they look as
Garrity but it's good and this is not
gonna come particularly podcast yeah you
both resent sip arguments
listen do you have any dates
I do Dave December 27th through the 29th
I'll be at the American comedy club in
San Diego California
January 4th through the 6th I will be at
the Syracuse funnybone in New York
that's it yeah that's it for now you
last time you shut up Dave forgot where
what city it was shut up Dave and you
called it did you make up that Tanner
was out of town it's a town and and so
you said the wrong one we're gonna be in
Phoenix on the 18th of January what a
fun recollection now we're gonna be Los
Angeles on the 19th of January we're
gonna be in Philadelphia on the 8th of
February and then we'll be in Atlanta on
the 9th of February so tickets are
available at salt Podcast calm that's
right those are all the right cities
that's right we have a was a bit of a
weird episode to begin with pushes let's
do the ads first now unless you know you
have something else here hey just so you
guys know I just got a notification that
medicine cabinets are trending on
Pinterest maybe it's time to take down
some of the notifications you get on
your phone we the dollop are sponsored
by ADT ADT can design and install a
smart home just for you backed by 24/7
protection a new smart home at your
service customized for your lifestyle
your lifestyle Hardy boy explore that
vast number of things you can do with
your secure smart home set up custom
automations unique to your home to
automatically do things it's just a
weird thing to do when I'm don't groom
other people when I'm doing keep going
lock the doors and set the thermostat
when you leave even close your garage
door from virtually anywhere do you want
to
you've got some grubs in your hair I'd
like to give you you could control your
smart home okay you like a ATT app or
the sound of your voice don't worry
about installing and configuring your
system ADT well di F why do it for you
ADT will set up I'm going through
puberty that's why it's kids yeah yeah
ATT will set up your home with multiple
smart home devices and security features
like indoor and outdoor cameras locks
lights and garage door control you know
you don't know all all controlled from
the ADT app or the sound of your voice
and backed by 24/7 protection I'm Dave
in the toilet please call to action oh
I'm not supposed to read that
visit att.com slash podcast to learn
more about how ATT can design Dave and
his toilet and install a secure smart
home just for you that's ADT comm /
podcast so that's our podcast or just a
podcast it's yeah it's just podcast just
general podcast okay they don't need
easy to track they'll need to get a
specific sure and and then they'll save
your life when the people come computer
Dave in the bathtub please that's not a
thing yeah we can set up that service if
you want so my brother comes in oh god
oh god help me guys blue apron is a
company that they're they send meals to
humans and you can cook them you can
take the meal sure you put together you
cook it blue aprons got a new WWE free
stop plan that features six chef's
design recipes every week get out yeah
clothes choose up to three ww freestyle
recipes per week receive pre-portion
ingredients and create delicious meals
huh for as low as four smart points each
sure sure yeah
Gareth and I cook a blue apron I share
together we'll make a spaghetti here huh
or a meat thing that all do and then
you'll look at it
and you won't eat it sure and you'll
judge me uh-huh
and I'll eat it okay and even though I
don't eat red meat
I'll eat it and I'll cry all right and
that's how we make our meals okay all
right
oh sure you can check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
at blue apron okay what calm slash what
what a you know this week they have the
seared steak and loaded mashed potatoes
uh-huh and those are loaded with money
magic mushrooms okay
and also a creamy saffron risotto
how do you do medium-rare with your mind
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free at blue apron
comm slash dollop that's blue apron comm
slash dollar blue apron the better way
to cool whoa I came in hot really
Lexus plan let's let's just blame what's
happening let's just plain it um okay so
we record we've recorded this episode in
the way that Dave wrote it and we did in
Houston with the hilarious Daniel Van
Kirk very funny man uh unfortunately
there was a technical glitch where it
wasn't at all recorded at all and the
guy said he never took the recorder
uh-huh from us yeah which is weird cuz
he brought it back he gave us one so
we're up one which is nice so the
decision to not record was made and so
but because it is topical and something
Dave is very excited about it has to be
it has to be as Dave would say we're
gonna record it again so I've heard this
yeah who knows how much I'll remember
well we very much okay but we've brought
in a special guest Pam Reynolds my
lovely mother oh my god I didn't see you
hi
yeah so that's what happened to this
episode so we recorded it so I've heard
it you've never heard and it's about
George HW Bush if you're did you know
that he's good do you like did you like
him I think I did but I think I liked
him when you died because everybody else
did why I'm here well there we go now
enter my job mother explaining CNN let's
straighten out let's straighten out the
the history of the man known as George
Herbert Walker Bush I know some people
think it's wrong to to do this right
after he's died but it's worse to act
like he was a great man and to be fair
we did this closer to when he died
already
so we've this is the second most
disrespectful it's been that's we did a
more disrespectful timing much much more
distress about a week ago I've onstage
yeah in the cities from the end the city
its remand for some reason that didn't
get recorded what a weird as a weird
decision what a weird thing that I
wouldn't get recorded in Houston of all
places you would think you would think
that Houston would be like let's record
this you talking conspiracy bro
yep June 12 1924 see he's not even
yelling it anymore he's not yelling the
date he's he's over it yeah yeah but
this this is a callback okay we like
your read June 12 19 24 I love what I'm
here
George Herbert Walker Bush was born in
Massachusetts to Prescott Sheldon Bush
and Dorothy Walker Bush very rich people
there's a very rich sounding name yeah
Prescott no.1 names there and gives
their son a middle name of Sheldon
unless they're losing cash yeah they
moved to Greenwich Connecticut right
after his birth which is where poor
people go sure and their vacation in
Kennebunkport Maine Oh God look at this
terrible place Shea yeah it's sad yeah
they had a hard time George went to
exclusive private schools 1924 s
grandfather had founded the Union
Banking
operation the bank was set up for a
German steel magnate George's dad was on
the board of directors beginning in 1934
who is the steel magnate I forgot the
name but who it's a relative No so his
Georges grandfather set up a bank just
it was specifically set up to help the
steel magnate in Germany okay do his
money stuff okay right in 1941 which
sounds good and that around this time is
on the up and up to be if we're trying
to help out Germany yeah what can go
wrong in 1941 the New York Herald
reported quote Hitler's angel has three
million in US bank and he didn't hear
Hitler's angel a lot no well they fought
the Hells Angels and killed them they
did slowly now we know the guy we know
them at the steel magnate was a huge
backer of Hitler because he wrote an
autobiography called quote I paid Hitler
yeah well I mean it's funny so far how
little I remember I paid Hitler mine
cash about the steel magnate and Hitler
had fallen out in 1939 but a
congressional investigation looked into
it and found it was not Nazi money that
the New York Herald that reported was in
a bank but the bank was part of a
network of companies that were aiding
the Nazis here and if you know the Nazis
but they weren't great guys
well Nazi adjacent yeah is a Nazi yep
right for where I'm from yeah you got a
picture we didn't get I have pictures
there's there's daddy
there's daddy uh-oh that's Prescott Bush
yeah you can see it see the douchebag in
the eye yeah yeah yeah yeah folded hanky
yeah yeah I think that's $1,000 bill
crumpled up there to light a cigar with
later
so Prescott was director he was named in
the report by by Congress
UBC was then seized by the United States
under the trading with the enemy Act
okay so here's that director George
Bush's dad was a director of a company
that was seized for helping the Nazis
it's weird because you would think that
some of those tendencies would rub off
in the future generations No yeah okay
no not at all okay
Nazis not hereditary no okay after
looking at the book seamless steel
Equipment Corp was also implicated as
fronting for the Nazis it was managed by
a guy named Prescott Bush now that's two
snots he strikes again
that is not good yeah but the bank was
not broken up and after the war it was
returned to its American shareholders
it's believed that Prescott sold his
shares for 1.5 million well that's how
you learn a lesson
yeah well that's teaching them yeah
that'll show you for helping the nah
what did I get from working with the
Nazis besides 1.5 mil yeah a lot of
people at the time thought he should
have been imprisoned because that's what
the law grounds working with the enemy
yeah anyway anyway right before that
scandal broke young George joined the US
Navy did you know about the bushes and
the Nazis are you surprised you're
getting from that micro oh I'm very
shocked actually yes I didn't have any
charge Bush's father yes pressed Sheldon
Prescott oh I don't have any photos of
him as a as a soldier which is fine but
he you know you mean in the third right
gear no no no he he fought at George
fought for us he joined the Navy on his
18th birthday okay and he quickly became
a pilot in just three days before his
19th birthday he was the youngest pilot
in the Navy he's gonna be the youngest
one it takes you three days to get your
license yeah really fast he was assigned
to the USS a San Jacinto and
name's skin because he was so lanky sure
I know it doesn't make much sense we
have like skin hanging off of you she
will will get law yeah no no really yeah
he flew in the South Pacific and during
a raid was shot down skin your skin's
got the propeller again to his crew
members were killed goose and Iceman yep
okay so you know the story well I heard
it once yeah yeah no no no no no mom
my mother has a goose friend in England
no no I've seen oh yeah great video the
goose yeah that's a good goose yeah yep
so he had he over the years he had
different stories of how the guys died
because his captain you're supposed to
relay the pilot yeah you're supposed to
jump out last uh-huh I'm supposed to
make sure your crew is safe and then you
go but there's different versions of
what happened so potentially he
prematurely ejaculated but that's one of
those things we you know give the guy a
break on that one because because yours
you're like in the throes of death Yeah
right so you're like hey I'm sorry about
all that protocol nonsense so George
spent 90 minutes in the sea before being
rescued all the time they were trying to
kill him and jets were jets but planes
were circling around American planes to
try and keep him safe while fighting off
the enemy so the whole thing okay other
guys got captured in and their livers
eaten by the Japanese pardon yep there
that I know they were very cool the
Japanese yeah but they ate the livers of
some of the men that they took yeah I
think yeah you're not surprised by the
livery no I live at where's the bacon
yeah what chips with 900 is the gravy
gravy on it yeah liver is it fryer liver
and gravy so after he got rescued he
went back to flying missions he ended up
flying 58 combat missions and was
decorated with the Distinguished Flying
Cross and three air medals
and then he was sent to Norfolk our Navy
base to train other pilots and he
married Barbara Pierce Barbara Pierce
that's exciting she is a woman okay the
names of some weirdo look at the guys I
hope they don't notice the dick sized
doll so George was honorably discharged
on September 1945 it was also later that
night in the wedding but little little
Prescott your mother's here that's two
back to back dick jokes yeah you're
welcome let me yep
so after that one month of the Japanese
surrendered he's out he goes to Yale
Prescott was on the university board so
that probably helped you think that that
helps if your father is on the board
Yale yeah right George join a fraternity
he was on the baseball team he played in
the first two College World Series okay
and most importantly just like his dad
he went on he was on the Yale
cheerleading squad right sure mm-hmm
and so was all three yeah all three of
them were cheerleaders really laugh at
that we've definitely gotten away from
that yeah it's it's stupid I think I
think that would be a nice way to change
up cheerleading again yeah like split it
with guys get 50% men in there you know
every time when I watch college
basketball and every time I look at the
Chili's I'm like what are you doing
what's your professional cheerleaders
our plate are paid [ __ ] no the garbage
they're paid laughs and $50 a game or
something like that yeah it's [ __ ]
terrible it's one of the things I think
it's exposure for you yeah I'm in Ohio
what kind of exposure am I getting hey
you can't buy this kind of press for the
two seconds before we go to commercial
show the score
so he wasn't initiating the Skull and
Bones secret society like his dad it has
always been a writ full of rich powerful
people the skullenbones society right
George did this all in two-and-a-half
years that's how long it took him to
graduate which I have nothing but
disrespect for people back then who got
through college because College you're
not paying for it back then it's right
especially him he's not it doesn't fight
you take your sweet-ass time in college
right now they got to do it in two and a
half years because when I went to
college I feel Rodney Dangerfield I went
to college for six and three quarters
years yeah but your sadhana because it
was cheapest [ __ ] yeah it was like it
was like it started $300 a quarter by
the time I was nine honey it cost
nothing so just ride the [ __ ] way
yeah yeah no respect it's weird by day
to be a cheerleader and by night to be
in like some janitorial closet like
drinking lambs blood in the skullenbones
I mean but that's the fun of it yeah
that is the fun after George graduated
he went to work for dresser industries a
family connected firm that provided
services to the oil industry you can
imagine that somehow he got connected
George Barbra and their firstborn George
W were sent to Odessa Texas dresser was
a company that provided cover for CIA
operatives okay
heard of them yes so dresser is oil and
CIA yeah so a lot of good stuff
everything it's great like you combined
finally combined a government agency
with the toxic fuel that's right that's
cool so Yale was a big funnel into the
CIA annex a officer named Osborn day
from the Yale class of 43 quote Yale has
always been the agency's biggest feeder
43 men from Yale's class of 1943 entered
the intelligence it's gotta be hard to
remain covert when you're like walking
around like
today my man I mean nothing I mean I
mean czar to Chell Nick hello sir I mean
essentially they're just rich kids who
can get jobs at places and then do stuff
right because if you're another guy if
you're just a random dude then you have
to try to get that job whereas these
guys automatically have jobs so of
course I'll see if we sort of you it's
sort of legacy base than a way to write
like they're they know who your father
is you're kind of vetted in a second
your dad's a Nazi so why not have you
you're checking a lot of boxes for us
Prescott all the illegal funds the ties
to Nazis good Lord make us want it a
little more would you so uh so yeah
don't look at the pictures we're gonna
do a picture part yeah so so dresser
moves its headquarters to Dallas and
George was with them the Bush family had
a friend Allen Dulles who became deputy
director in charge of clandestine
operations in the CIA so you know double
secret right [ __ ] right the Dulles
family had been in on the Nazi business
with Prescott
so Nazi businesses
sounds like a cartoon strip no it's
great when that doesn't matter right
it's great with Nazi on your resume it
just means like hey come on in well now
I mean it's more it's a great time now
it's helping yeah yeah so Prescott was
now running for Senate in Connecticut
and George was made the Midland County
chairman of the Eisenhower campaign in
1952 so I hope you've got a little
button or sash sash she wore sash I
would love for that to be honest it were
sash and he was really great yeah and
the swimsuit competition
yeah well skin how would he not be a man
geez where is it all coming from hello
boys
it's me skin yeah good yeah for your
talent I'm gonna cheer he so he's now
the link between
big Texas oil and the Republican
administration right so he's in a great
facial yep so George struck struck out
in the oil business on his own if you
invested in George HW Bush you're
getting the vast connections a Prescott
Bush who's super inside with the
Eisenhower administration so money is
rolling in now right in 1953
George joined up with Hugh and bill led
key to form Zapata Petroleum okay let
key had a quote hunch just had a hunch
he had a feeling about some stuff and
that led to a hundred and twenty seven
straight wells that came up with oil so
he had a right in the hot streak oh well
I mean it's either a hot streak or
something that the CIA helped with
because there's no [ __ ] way in hell
you Joe hundred twenty seven language
sorry is here apologize to ya ya mouth
I've heard would you quit making would
you quit just getting so angry at a hot
streak it's I bet you're the kind of guy
who thinks Barry Bonds doesn't belong in
the Hall of Fame because he used growth
hormone until his head looked like he
was some professor from the future who
could move items with his thoughts let
me say that I think he should be in the
Hall of Fame twice for being a great
baseball player and for having the
biggest head they should make two busts
when he was regular and one after [ __ ]
mother would love to see Barry Bonds as
head it will show you after it's really
something it's quite different I'll show
you the before and after yes really good
head fixed you don't go to it later no
it it proceeds after you stop doing it
steroids doesn't your once your head
gets that what happens you just get a
bunch of extra hair and skin you don't
know what about marker wires you still
have a giant head he's huge yeah James I
thought you went back down to small it's
not like some sort of wizard spell where
at the end of your movie look I'm
regular now
once you've made yourself enormous that
way should be in the Hall of Fame yeah
twice twice so you know it's a pot of
stock goes crazy from seven cents a
share to twenty three dollars super
lucky quite a jockey you've played the
market oh yes yeah okay
Zapata moved into offshore drilling in
1958 Zapatas oil rig named scorpion was
moved 54 miles north of Cuba nice
Operation Mongoose was a CIA program to
remove the communists from power in Cuba
so an oil well is a deadly insect and
then you go with Mongoose for the
operation interesting yeah interesting
interesting it's like you're trying to
cover something that's not there
one official quote George Bush one CIA
official quote George Bush would be
given a list of names of Cuban oil
workers we would want placed in jobs the
oil platforms were perfect for training
the Cubans on raids on their homeland so
the oil rig is simply a way to train
Cubans and then send them to Cuba to
attack and it's like a twofer yeah going
and then one you're up there you're like
overthrow the government we got a thing
going on humans yeah okay the pod
operations were set up in the Persian
Gulf
Trinidad Borneo Medine George was
constantly traveling Zapata started
helping the CIA pay off politicians in
Latin America
well David that's not legal well okay I
mean no okay it's not but the CIA gets
to do whatever it wants right there yeah
Li's yeah Zapata money flowed through
Mexico ex-cia agent quote Bush's company
was used as a conduit for these funds
under the guise of oil business
contracts and it's free CIA money
because if money doesn't go into the US
it's not taxed so he's just making money
and then giving it to whoever the CIA
wants it to go to through Mexico to the
Latin American contacts and now just
remember this guy will become president
yeah and he and I have you saw the
coverage but pretty great yeah
yeah you just got to ignore all this
stuff yeah yes Zapata did not have right
to pay taxes right so President Kennedy
John F I don't know if you know what
happened to him yeah not a great ending
he was assassinated on November 22nd
1963 what yeah oh you didn't know this
my god will do that episode later it
said every person to my old was he he
was 48 oh no 74 it is said every person
in America remembers exactly where they
were when they heard that Kennedy had
been killed except one person yeah we
went to the stock room and cried really
yes remember it's like 9/11 you remember
where you were you know who doesn't you
know doesn't remember where they were
when Kennedy was killed George HW Bush
oh he has no memory yeah yeah George
George Bush has no idea where he was he
said he was quote somewhere in Texas
well that's where the assassination took
place the FBI knew where George was from
an FBI report on the day of the shooting
quote quote somewhere in Texas is
actually at 1:45 p.m. mr. George HW Bush
president of Zapata offshore drilling
company telephonically furnished the
following information to writer by
long-distance telephone from Tyler Texas
Bush stated he want to be kept
confidential but wanted to furnish here
say that he recalled hearing in recent
weeks the day and source unknown
he stated that one James Parrott had
been talking of killing the president
when he comes to Houston so so that's
what George orge was he was making a
call from Tyler Texas to the FBI but he
doesn't remember where he was it's Shady
what it's very Shady we also remember
how much fun we had with the parent guy
in last the live guys
just such a fun run there it is there's
the FBI memorandum that's a little
strange
so I'm something with the pictures
you're cheating
you're totally cheating yeah yeah mm-hmm
so so there's tons of as a shitload of
conspiracy theories and weird
connections when it comes to Bush and
Kennedy and where he was and and who was
working with and blah blah blah I'm not
gonna wade through it because I don't
number one give a [ __ ] about the Kennedy
assassination but I also don't care
about conspiracy theories but we do know
that he lied and he knew knew who he was
and we actually we know what he was
doing when Kennedy was shot shooting the
president of the local Kiwanis Club says
George was giving a speech when he was
told of the assassination quote George
stopped his speech and told the audience
what happened and then finished reading
the story about that's right he said I
consider it inappropriate to continue
and then he sat down so it's at other
people to decide why a guy in the CIA
would make a phone call to establish
where he was to the FBI
honestly when they're saying that it
feels like it you've made the decision
no I mean I was to say involve the say
he's [ __ ] involved in everything
that's wrong
so probably somehow but I mean allegedly
the the thing that I've never looked
into that that the assassination stuff
but the thing that makes most sense to
me is that Oswald was a CIA operative
because he spent years in in the Soviet
Union and he did it so they were just
covering for that but that's what I
think anyway I haven't looked into it
like I said in 1964 George ran for
Congress in one so now he's super rich
from Zapata and obviously his daddy he
voted for the Civil Rights Act even
though most people in his district were
against it so that's actually a thing
good that's good he supported the
Vietnam War he was re-elected in 1968
Nixon saw George as a Nixon man
which means what she did well Nixon it
really it's for me or against me like
he's really right no it's good when
you're like you know Satan's coming to
my show tonight he's scouting me Nixon
convinced George to run for this
which he did in 1970 and lost okay okay
yeah
Nixon then named George ambassador of
the UN okay so he's moving up right
getting the credentials mm-hmm in the
1973 George became head of the
Republican National Committee under
Nixon but Nixon Nixon's pushing all that
yeah
then came Watergate now during Watergate
there were these burglars that broke in
to the DNC at first I've heard of it and
they were they were paid by people
somehow imagine Nixon like when he first
heard about it having to react like he
didn't know I can't I just one more time
the name of the place waffle low water
what water bridge I've never heard of
this place somehow the NOC damn it's hot
in here so have the Mexican see a
moneyline quote made its way into the
hands of the Watergate burglars and
interesting so the CA so the Watergate
burglars okay sounds like the CIA vault
yeah and then I don't know what company
does business down there but there's a
like maybe some sort of Mexican how
about Zapata company that company yeah
so it turns out we know someone who has
a see a Mexican connection and it's
close to it whatever yeah as watergate
broke and evidence mounted George came
to be seen as an Nixon apologist so
imagine it's clear that a president has
done something very criminal and then
there are a bunch of guys in his party
who were like that's not true even
though it's getting more and more
obvious every day here it's just such a
weird imagine but then at some point
like a recording came out or something
came out and it was [ __ ] over it was
too obvious right and then George
requested Nixon resigned for the good of
the party so he's out for becomes
president and then Ford picks George to
be director of the CIA right this is
before he pardoned Nixon or this is
after I don't know before after I think
I think after so the Democrats
controlled the Senate it was 60 seats if
you can imagine that uh-huh
and a lot of them that's the most
fantastical thing of this whole yes
filibuster proof Senate or Senate
Democrats a lot of them are still angry
that George had been such a partisan
hack during Watergate plus the CIA is a
[ __ ] show at this point it had been
revealed the CIA was spying domestically
which is not supposed to do attention so
could you imagine the see ad well now
they just now our phones do it for them
yeah yeah it's pretty simple
a CIA investigation dug up CIA scandal
after scandal after scandal all right
sorry we're idiot a senator so the
Senate is the Democratic Senate is
investigating and they're just digging a
thing after [ __ ] [ __ ] show that's not
good so if this Senate confirmed George
he would be the first partisan
politician to run the CIA so before this
is open military guys are business guys
but has never been a guy who played Emma
Kratt and then taking over the CIA okay
so this would be a holy thing I'm sure
wave to ride yeah so the Democrats came
out hard against him and it didn't look
good for George during the during the
hearings your mom's very excited this is
audio mainly she actually watched oh
look at that she watched one of the
recordings when she was on this show on
YouTube and what it was one of the
comments someone said what I think I
googled you one day cuz I was right see
if my computer was working and so I
can't remember I think she's one lady
said something about me and then some
and then she said she sounds like a
lovely old British lady sounds like a
lovely old British subject replied and
said Gareth Reynolds mother is not old
that's right I know
Trump feels now yeah oh well yeah
because you have a soul so I don't know
if you know that but yeah okay so he's
about to not get confirmed yes so it's
not going good and then eight days after
the hearing a CIA station chief was
assassinated in Greece okay
he'd been living in the same house as
the previous station chiefs and had been
publicly ID'd in the papers everyone
knew who he was and where he lived and
he works for the CIA yes he's the
station chief okay so they now in Greece
know who the CIA station chief is and
where he is and where are you so local
militant group had been watching him for
months and they kill him right they
weren't doing a great job they were like
where the hell is it we're watching I
mean they're watching CIA and White
House are all over it they blame the
Democrats the plane carrying his body
back quote circled Andrews Air Force
Base for three quarters of an hour in
order to land live during the Today Show
which is what you want when you're like
if you're the family of someone like
that you're like it's good for him to
get up like it's what this is about the
right stuff this is how you're supposed
to do it I feel like you don't know what
the right stuff is keep him going around
for a few hours until the cameras are
ready photo perfect photo yeah yeah so
the guys I know you landed can we do one
more where he just looks a little more
into it I mean hey cor here's what I'm
thinking plane comes down yes hand is
hanging out no this is what I'm talking
about somebody who thinks a little
outside in the fire talking about the
gasket gang sorry I said box I'm sorry I
know that your son Oh anyway alright
that's lunch and after we get back from
lunch we're gonna try to get this one
guys let's really get this one the
outgoing CIA director blame the station
Chiefs death on quote the sensational
and hysterical way the CIA
investigations have been handled and
trumpeted around the world so just
blaming Democrats for the guy's death
even though it's clearly the way it is
like the invention of partisanship to it
on this level right I mean there's
always partisanship but this is a
different yeah this is a gear shift this
yeah right
for sure but that's what happens when
you try and put a partisan guy on the
shirt so there's zero evidence that any
of this was true right the Democrats had
nothing to do with it but the public no
longer
or it's the CIA investigation that's the
result right Strom Thurmond argued it
was time he was if you don't spend god
best racer Minh had a had a child with
his black mate so he's Strom Thurmond
argued was time to confirm confirm
George because the public no longer
cared for the Senate quote tearing down
the CIA also it's time for more blood
and I can't see your blood I'm so old
what more blood in me and they needed
quote this highly competent man to
repair the damage of this overexposure
this highly competent man after Strom
speech that day George is confirmed by a
vote of twenty of sixty four to twenty
seven
it's weird that the Democrats are back
down but they yeah they used to do that
back then so this is when the Democrats
didn't have a spine yeah now where it's
like they are like the hardcore leaders
who get it that's why they say stone
schumer cuz it's like he's made yeah
right yeah what the senate had not
learned was the chest Schumer's boneless
right yes okay skin's opposite like the
bushes yeah what the senate had not
learned was that the CIA was in the
middle of something called Operation
Condor in nineteen seventy five six
South American dictatorships in
Argentina Bolivia Brazil Chile Paraguay
and Uruguay oh boy I can't like these
aren't that's good that these aren't
coming up what's wrong with your stupid
uh what's wrong hey Aaron you're stupid
I'm gonna blame you yeah it's stupid do
it again so these these six countries
South American countries conspired to
eliminate their left-wing opponents and
dissidents their intelligence services
traded information in order to kidnap
and kill domestic leftists in their own
countries and then traded information
about X Isles who would run away in in
other countries do you ever feel like
history repeats itself I don't know why
you would say that okay history is never
repeated itself okay and we are all good
that's too bad Aaron I will fight you
why don't you just click on one well
because then another picture might come
out well this is the best this is the
best podcast has ever been done by the
way with the way we is it oh yeah that's
it that's the one okay so this is kind
of oh no that's not it
it's not that's a different thing that
goes wrong I'm not a good one oh that's
a bad one oh I guess I guess that's not
here I love you guys what the hell was
that okay so here's a picture of that's
just chilly that's a museum in Chile of
all the people who disappeared or were
killed by this Operation Condor
they traded information to find where
exiles were hiding people were put in
concentration camps there were death
squads people were tortured interrogated
executed and secretly buried these were
union leaders peasants leaders priests
nuns students teachers and elections and
suspected guerrillas and the CIA played
a huge part well because they're awesome
and Bush is now in charge of yes and
Bush's dad is a Nazi immediate yeah it's
weird it is weird okay
the CIA trained and funded the
intelligence directors of these
countries they gave access to
sophisticated US communication networks
the operation was running under George
when he was director of the CIA a
Chilean dissident named Orlando Letelier
who is
this gentleman here was living in DC he
had escaped from Chile he had been a
concentration camp and he was very vocal
against a dictator Augusto Pinochet on
September 21st 1976 he was killed by a
car bomb as was an American woman in the
car with him so they were killed the
mastermind was the Chilean intelligence
chief and a paid asset of the CIA it
feels like the CIA had something to do
with some of this a little bit yeah
turns out the CIA knew that he was
responsible but George had the CIA leak
a document clearing the Chilean
intelligence service was it just like
the same letter that was when he was in
Texas is the same thing as before yeah I
think you'll find it nobody did anything
so he purposefully put out a let even
though this guy had killed an American
citizen and a dissident in Washington DC
right George Bush put out a letter to
lead the FBI in the wrong direction
so he purposefully says that this guy
did not do it and pushes them in the
wrong direction right Newsweek the CIA
quote the CIA agency reached its
decision because the bomb was too crude
to be the work of experts and because
the murder coming while Chile's rulers
were wooing US support could only damage
the Santiago regime so it was such a
shitty bomb that there's no [ __ ] way
that Chilean government could do it
right because it was so bad it's so bad
like fake nobody could make something
this bad I mean it's genuine dumbass
this is a [ __ ] bomb it worked it worked
great it worked
super good sure if the point of a bomb
is to just make it go off and kill ya
and kill the guy that you're trying to
buy yes if you're going to talk about
having a little fun
after a fan that's right into the
candies out of the pinata well not this
is below expectation right not our guys
this is not good
our guys so if I can give you like a
sound difference like if our guys did a
bomb it would have been like oh but this
one was like so not our guys yeah I mean
or their or the other when I say our I
mean not our our guy our guy the other
guys we're saying are as in the letter
are our guys that's what they call
themselves they got a commercial so
George as head of the CIA protected
assets who killed an American citizen
and a dissident on United States soil
also murderers chattering a lot of
firsts yeah which is cool also a
murderous dictator could continue to
kill off people who were leftists George
served one year CIA director President
Carter booted him in 1980 he ran for
vice president sorry but George couldn't
beat Reagan he was too good
Reagan was too smart empty-headed he was
however picked to be Reagan's vice
president that was very very no where
the [ __ ] is that language well if it's
about who looks more comfortable putting
their hands up and Reagan deserve to win
look at George Bush puts his hand
everything I can't believe I raised it
so so there is no evidence of what
happened with Reagan in the Iranian
hostage crisis but there are accusations
George and Reagan's campaign manager met
secretly with Iran to keep the hostages
from being freed until Reagan was
president right what we do know is that
an hour after Reagan became president a
plane took off from Tehran with all the
hostages on it so that's just a
coincidence Carter might have been one
delayed flight away from I mean I don't
want to blame it on the baggage handlers
delays hey Carter closed the door and
then he's like hello
go get out of here in July 1979 the
Sandinistas took over a nicaragua after
fighting for a decade against the Somoza
dictatorship so leftists are in power in
Nicaragua
finally Reagan and George no light no
light no like why leftist come on yeah
in 19 of the oppositus Nazis
yeah it's true in a way in 1981 CIA
director William Casey laid out a plan
to launch a secret war against the
Sandinistas George backed it Reagan
approved and the Contras were born you
guys love the Contras right sure most of
what I know about Reagan is from killer
Mike song Reagan yeah 15,000 strong in
August 1982 Congress passed the Boland
Amendment forbidding the u.s. from
financing the overthrow of the
Sandinistas okay so it was officially
yeah they're like do not do this we do
not want this happening okay shut it
down because it'll make things worse
okay so you're saying we do not don't
don't do it don't do it do we don't want
it we don't want it nope don't do
anything to pay for it or trade with
them or anything to none of it yeah and
what if we you know what if we were to
accidentally don't what if okay can I
just are at a hypothetical situation
yeah okay we're all hanging out okay
okay at a pick me up we're at a picnic
but we have separate picnic areas Yeah
right now it's a really bad okay okay so
there's a bunch of picnic there's two
different picnics and there's a picnic
air and there's separate picnic areas
and in between the two picnic areas is a
bunch of money now can we help the
Sandinistas lift up the money know it
and put it in their things no no help
Wow MLC you know helping the same and we
give them money no okay that's the whole
thing we just said you can't okay yeah
I've just that's the picnic thing threw
me off your idea when you said the
picnic thing there I didn't say the
picnic
whoever said it it doesn't matter the
point is it's a pretty good you said it
and it's not a good point okay there's
no money no helping what mark may I
throw one more huh everybody's
skinny-dipping this is a separate thing
everybody's skinny-dipping I
accidentally switched my pants that has
a lot of money and weapons in it with
one of the Sandinistas pants no and he
doesn't realize until he's miles away
and I don't realize till I'm miles away
then I think it's better if he keeps
those pants even if it has money and
arms in it and arms well I'll think of
these pants I know pants are normally
four legs but these are arm pants how
much money I mean what is enough to get
him to go away I guess to go to go away
well I mean you know what is it you a
bill I don't know as much as they need
to do what we say I guess is how much is
in the pants no none of that's okay well
I'm glad we did this because now I know
what is okay and what is not okay I'm
worried is what I'm concerned I'm gonna
call them and get their routing number
I'll give them a piece of my mind
okay so within days of the Boland
amendment passing ahead of the CIA Casey
had a new operation running now George
HW Bush was in charge interesting he was
not a normal vice president he was quote
in the loop on talk secret top secret
stuff well they wanted to the president
of the vice president to be aware of
what was happening okay what'd he say
George well okay so he is in the loop on
toxic good stuff top secret stuff and
approving weapons for the Contras his
operation became known as Black Eagle
names are getting cooler so George
brought in CIA operative or ex operative
he his name is Donald Gregg so what
happens is Donald Gregg comes in and
Donald Gregg is a CIA guy and then
after he comes in he leaves the CAA so
he immediately gets a job in the White
House then immediately to CIA which a
lot of people call that a weird cover-up
it's a clearly he's still doing a CIA
operation you think that he had you
can't do both
so Greg became George's national
security advisor now previous vice
president's national security adviser
would just like prep oversea trips like
if you're going to Paraguay they go down
and go like hey the president's gonna
come here's the hotel he's staying in
this Cabana these towels likes a good
mai tai but Greg is all involved with
the Contras and what the Contras are
doing and and and as a vice president no
one has done what George has done before
in a good way or not they are not in the
loop all right top secret [ __ ] right
so also Panamanian dictator general
Manuel Noriega also became involved with
this operation black eagle he he got he
got involved because the Mossad
introduced him to Greg and the game wait
the Mossad is the Israeli it's not okay
they are involved and this is we just
call this guy Greg I just love that
Panama's just got so many people just
doing horseshit of the Masonic all you
want to meet their general areas what
drinking we're going Vegas Noriega then
allowed Black Eagle planes to land in
Panama and use Panamanian companies to
hide payroll so so they're flying in
with the guns and the money and stopping
in Panama it's a great setup
yeah it's great I mean if you get away
with it this is a real winner it's nice
now Nora had always been buddies with
the CIA sure yeah it's how he stayed off
the US radar
so he's never in trouble because he's
always given up information that seems
to be how you become friends with the
other yeah in 1976 when he was
intelligence director in Panama he was
he was a CIA informant he it's terrible
for Panama he even had a meeting always
seemed like that one step ahead even at
a meeting at the Panamanian Embassy in
DC with George HW Bush who was a CIA
counterpart at that time okay so they've
known each other since nice very
familial yeah George and Manuel met
again in December 1983 good to see him
man wait my George happen to be in South
America on a you know VP business George
reassured Noriega he would always be an
important United States ally and as soon
as Noriega was involved in Black Eagle
he began using the planes to run drugs
into the United States so wait so and
again I've heard this but this so
Noriega so these planes are US planes
well they're secret secret right but
they are they're CIA plane they're under
US control right okay so they're using
them to run arms weapons to them and
money get money and then to buy weapons
with the money right and then run the
money and then the weapons enough for
Noriega he's like we also got a
moonlight as drug planes yes so he's got
the drug he now he as soon as the planes
are landing he's filling him up with
drugs and saying take these into the US
okay so the guys who are who are pilots
for the CIA are now flying drugs into
the u.s. right he steps it up a little
bit hey it's it's yeah it's definitely
take it up a notch kind of thing instead
of stopping it the u.s. made a deal one
percent of the drug in come from Noriega
splaine's was set aside to buy weapons
for the Contras you know it would have
been nice if you finished that with like
you know Toys for Tots but instead it's
like one percent has to go these are
gonna go to death squad the death squads
okay it became overtime
roll million dollars that 1% which just
goes to show how much Noriega is making
right I was [ __ ] drugs right people in
Black Eagle say George Bush was very
aware of Noriega drug flights it's cool
it's totally cool
that's I have a picture yeah hey left
all the way to the bank
morning and night yeah you're cheating
it's just really bad you're doing it
right now you're just the microphone I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm just so taken with
your pictures David good just impressive
yeah he took all these yes there is
there is on the coke flights yeah this
is your captain Manuel Noriega we are
cooked to the nines ladies and gentlemen
fasten your seatbelts I'm kidding do
whatever the [ __ ] you like so um so he's
super cocky Noriega and the reason he's
cocktail is because he like to blackmail
people and had hidden video and audio
equipment in government offices all over
Panama so he began to compile a dossier
dossier on Bush and black eagle and his
staff and everything he had copies of
Black Eagle reports and videotapes of
meetings that's a lot yeah he's got a
lot of [ __ ] yeah so Reagan and George
ran for a second term
George was snippy on the campaign trail
I want to talk about it he's happy but I
don't want to talk about it Ron
when he was asked well to be honest when
we were getting on the bus you jumped
ahead of me and I was waiting for you to
go on and then you took so long and then
by the time I was ready to get on the
bus you decided to get on the bus this
looked like I was standing and now that
I look like I was standing out there
just holding the door open for you to
get on the bus this is this and by the
way it's our anniversary this is the
worst snippy ever like it's the slowest
most meandering when George was asked by
reporters why his stance on abortion had
changed because Ron wouldn't let me on
the goddamn pass he said he couldn't
remember his previous stance on abortion
once how do you forget your stance on
abortion you forget it when I land on
that where I am now I've always been
against abortion I think no no you used
to not be against the board well I don't
remember that I'm pro-life choice I
don't remember I'm anti boy when
reporters asked him how he couldn't
remember he said quote they're an awful
lot of things I don't remember
awful lot like he's just some like
grandma who's like well I can't remember
where my needed needles are where my
prisoners are so many things I don't
know what's happening the lack going on
right now I've got a bunch of recipes in
my head and I can't remember which one I
was gonna make thereupon was Walter
Mondale he picked congresswoman
Geraldine Ferraro to be his VP George
had to debate her he seemed to resent
debating a woman right he was hyper
aggressive and at one point called out
Ferraro for exaggerating about terrorism
and saying Democrats didn't care that
the brains have been blown up in
favorite yeah well those talking points
are still like no but it is so prevalent
where it's just like like how do you win
it that or how do you care how did that
ever stick to someone where it was like
well yeah but she hates the army you
heard what he said
so Mondale asked for an apology and
George refused to give an apology and
the next day George was overheard saying
quote I tried to kick a little ass and
then he noticed a reporter saw him and
hurt him and said quote whoops my god he
heard me turn that thing off yeah yeah
that's like what someone says spoiler
alert after they've ruined the movie for
you if the guy gets his head blown off
at the end boiler okay
well you know we actually we're we're
the ones that killed Kennedy
yeah shut her down please no more
recording it is brain oh come on mister
his staff then showed up on the press
plane wearing buttons that said we
kicked a little ass you know it's pretty
easy to hate the candidate but a lot of
times it's it's really fun to hate the
staff yeah just like look at u-dub shits
some reporters started calling him
kick-ass George skin yeah
others wore hats made of jock straps I
already have I feel like that's a
different way we're like they were doing
something else that's underwear those
are not hats Mondale hat man
it's a jockstrap awesome yeah we're
pretty great yeah I got my mitt said I'm
a dong and my dong head I'm bad what I'm
playing flippy-floppy with hats okay
it's not a good look
it's a jockstrap there's cocaine on this
pits on your what there's a lot of
cocaine okay let's go Mondale though
said George quote doesn't have the
manhood to apologize whoa Doonesbury
ran a cartoon about George's lack of
manhood though this time as VP George
was called Reagan's Lackey the
president's brown-nosing yes-man so he's
getting it from all sides and get a
brown-nose when you wear a jockstrap for
a head I do throughout and it got worse
oh it all still the stuff sticking to
him the man had stuff the column of
Lackey and a brown-noser
he had [ __ ] ish behavior during the
campaign the Washington Post wrote quote
he seems to reveal himself as blustering
opportunistic Craven and hopelessly
ineffective all at once people have this
idea that George Bush was like
well-spoken and decent president and my
memory of him is that he was a bumbling
[ __ ] idiot but here's the problem he
had a son who was even worse that's
right it's a weird how is some dumber
but he's when you see them together
you're like oh boy HW was really smart
yeah well Bush well he was just like
Reagan was a [ __ ] idiot
well Bush was a [ __ ] idiot about that
the next Bush was a [ __ ] idiot
now we have a colossal David borderline
hamster in the [ __ ] White House who
are you talking about thank you
what do you mean thank you very much in
October I love and in tow huge in
October 1984 Congress pact passed a
second Boland Amendment to stop payment
to the concrete conscious now anything
you can give anything but humanitarian
aid right now they're just like
seriously don't
okay well hypothetical quite
hypothetical situation if we may since
we have to go through this all again
yeah okay all right one of the Contras
has terrible breath yeah and I run into
them and they say to me can I have a
breath mint can I give them a breath
mint
no I can't give a contra a breath mint
no okay well what if inside the breath
mint is a hundred billion dollars no I
can't give him a breath mint we just
said you can't get my breath mint
hypothetical we fight a treasure map and
their treasure is buried by me and I
give them the map at x marks the spot
no okay it's a great area it's not black
eagle operatives were becoming leery of
Noriega and the drug runs weird agent
lou archer studio 54 airlines wasn't
working out agent lou archer quote he
would get somebody to take a load to the
US and presto he's got you for life
this is his modus operandi compromised
somebody and then blackmail him now at
this point the Mossad gets out of the
operation because they're so freaked
about about every Noriega is doing and
people are becoming aware of what's
happening and the Mossad and the CIA end
up pulling guns on each other or the
Black Eagle guys in a and like an
operation house in Panama and I'm not
cheating each other but they get so far
and so heated that they actually pull
guns on each they reservoir dogs' each
other yeah
in a shed without the year coming off
right that's the whole thing
no guys here come Oliver North's
operation Enterprise also to fund the
Contras was getting going as George's
Blackie Eagle was wrapping up George Mel
over North use this yeah okay
yeah yeah so George is then in the loop
and he's kept up to speed on every
fundraising activity of oliver north so
he knows all the money and everything is
happening with all north which is as we
know a lot of illegality that's that's
weapons coming from the Middle East I
think at first they're coming from
Lebanon and then eventually Iran and it
turns out we're not friends with Iran
it's also weird that people think that
the u.s. started bringing coke into this
country and afflicted the nation with
the drug to bridge the gap between
operations another operation was started
its operations on operation called
supermarket which ran out of Miami
ticket dive the Dade County a Republican
Party chairman was raising money for it
quote the word on the street was that
Jeb was the man to see if he wanted to
help the contras us evening news Jeb's
got all the brains that skin did CBS
Evening News the Miami Herald and other
legitimate media outlets reported Jeb's
involvement when the story broke and
then it just disappeared and no one ever
discussed the story again so media has
been working for a while yeah it's all
been happening for a long time now a
plane was shot down in Noriega - the
guys in the plane died in Nicaragua one
did not and there he is yeah looks like
he's like boy I'm glad I'm alive so word
is now out about the operations
immediately u.s. there's a see a guy
u.s. is funding the Contras Bush says he
knows nothing and Laura gate and yeah
what Watergate
[Music]
Bush says he knows nothing and even said
quote I'm catching the Dickens from
friends for not preventing the Iran arms
deal we have our victim I'm catching the
Dickens for my friend for not stopping
me my friend Ted over here keeps giving
me the Dickens
he's like why you stuffed Iran yeah and
I'm like I wish I could stop I'm like
can we you just focus on golf quit
razzing me so hard
so Oliver North starts shredding
documents a handwritten note was however
found in the later investigation from
George that thanked North for his quote
dedication and tireless work with the
hostage thing and with Central America
parenthetical cocaine stop
the special prosecutor was brought in to
investigate the iran-contra affair Bush
failed to hand over his diary quote
containing contemporaneous notes
relevant to the iran-contra
investigation boys can be so mean at
school he also refused to be interviewed
in the late stages of the investigation
weird
now the manhood thing kept cropping up
you know George is not a man so much so
that
doonesbury was now portraying him as
invisible oh wow so now this goes on for
years where Doonesbury just has George
as in visited some empty Roman helmet in
1987 Jeb Bush said in an interview quote
he's been reduced to a cartoon and this
was in Newsweek in an article titled
Bush battles the wimp factor so he
doesn't look like a wimp when he's just
like the Gorton's fisherman on a bad day
but so in order to prove that he's not a
wimp his son comes out he's like my dad
is not a [ __ ] I mean at one point I
can't remember what the circumstances
were but George W his son yelled like
they said it was something like how did
you think he did in the debates and he
was like macho like it was I think my
old man it's got a huge dick I think
he's got it I've seen his penis it's an
enormous pecker okay so this this Artur
this magazine article about him being
weapon news we came out the day he
declared to be running for president
George later could look like a bigger
wimp
yeah he looks terrible we're last George
a minute he wanted to quote kick the
hell
out of the doonesbury crater Gary
Trudeau I want to show him the Dickens
George then went on the campaign trail
George visited Auschwitz on September
29th 1987 he said cause my room he said
quote boy they were big on crematoriums
weren't they Wow is any part of him
trying to like is there some sort of
deniability that goes on there when if
you come crematoriums I can't I can't
emphasize how much the Trump campaign
the George W Bush campaign and the
George HW Bush campaigns were all the
same and that they said and did the
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] over and over and
over and all the media did it was
attacked the Democrat but it was
repeatedly endless [ __ ] nonsense
coming out of there idiot holes and they
were never hold to account right it
would just be like laughed off instead
of being like hey this guy might be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] which just goes to show
you that the the truth like the reality
is that you're always gonna have
corrupted [ __ ] who are trying to
take it all away from you there's a
referee who is supposed to report on
what reality is and tell you what's
important and know they and then they
just haven't done it at all they've
become like you'd like I mean it's like
the dog who gets fed from the dinner
table at this point it's like well don't
even put food in the dish anymore these
idiots just expect it when you eat yeah
so he's running against Michael Dukakis
in Massachusetts some Jed some said
George should pick a female UN
ambassador barbara Jean Kirkpatrick a
woman as his VP to add some quote
machismo to the ticket suggesting that
if I am a woman I will be rhetoric more
man screams what we're saying yeah look
at see and raise his arms
look at all his skin honey go get the
empty barbells George started making it
a point to eat pork rinds on the
campaign trail because he thought it
rights made him seem more manly
he's eating pork rinds because he thinks
it makes him manly that's it such a
Connecticut Kennebunkport Maine way of
thinking about don't know how you
big-city folk do it but down here we
just need a bunch of pork rinds no no no
lamb for me I'll have pork rinds the
reporter asked him if his public
perception work was it odds with reality
and George said quote much different for
example I like pork rinds that doesn't
fit the mold see I'm totally out of the
box I like pork rinds
a tough son-of-a-bitch I'm not a wimp on
the trail he sculpted environmentalists
against some pork rind who were against
the Alaska oil pipeline because it would
harm the caribou population quote
caribou like the pipeline they lean up
against it have a lot of babies and
scratch on it
there's more damn caribou than you can
shake a stick at that's like eight
different arguments that are all
incorrect and one yeah but it's exactly
what yeah we would say for sure it's
exactly you got the caribou they're
having sex with the pipeline from the
variability coming out of the kid a baby
caribou are some of the best caribou
we've ever seen we've never seen caribou
like this actually one of them came out
looked at me for his words out of his
mouth
dad thank you okay thank you in April in
Pennsylvania he said quote what's wrong
with being a boring kind of guy it would
be a bad idea to kind of suddenly get my
hair colored and dance up and down on a
miniskirt
I mean maybe I kind of think I'm a
scintillating kind of fellow and worst
came the worst case scenario if you look
at my hair and think it's been dyed
that's probably just me rubbing the pork
rinds in the old hair I always call that
hair
the heads napkin who's in who's in to me
skirt not handsome not not me that's a
good thing and I'm a hundred percent on
this I'm not a huge [ __ ]
period I'm scintillating alright now as
soon as Barbara comes out of the
bathroom I'll give her her bag back you
visited a New Jersey rehab clinic and
asked a patron patient quote what did
you start out on just for the heck of it
what about another quote did you come
here and say the heck with it I don't
need this darn thing did you go through
withdrawal thing so man if you could
just eliminate thing and question marks
he might pass during the campaign in
July so what you do you put out the junk
in the old vain thing but the old black
tar and the old vain thing in the old
armed thing with the old belt thing and
then you're like I'm done with this
thing you chase the Dragons tail thing
for a little while then you another
underworld thing and you don't send your
heart stops beating kind of thing and
what the next thing you know you face
faced with Satan thing kind of thing you
know as your dad's the devil you're
trying to get away from him but you
accidentally yeah it's one of those
things you certa yeah thing week where I
was suddenly you realize your dad's
devil and the only way you can get out
of the thing is cook you're bringing out
certain thing who I want some vodka I'm
buying kind of thing what huh that's our
thing it was pork rind No who wants pork
rind huh well at a budget I think the
all these guys in here bunch [ __ ] say
hey my pork rinds like me can he go away
this is not good for my sobriety I can't
eat any more pork rinds I'm dying I
think it sounds like the Duke of
Edinburgh wrote a script the to come out
of breath I was told he's known for
pretty whose foot in it
oh he was totally and still is wait
that's I'm not gonna make a guess who's
the Duke of Edinburgh
he's the Queen's husband Oh Oh what's
his name again
Philip that's right oh yeah he also puts
his his stuff in it on an island with
epstein allegedly third in 1988 an
Iranian airliner with 290 people on
board was shot down by the USS Vincennes
US officials reported the airliner was
off route descending rapidly and heading
for the Vincennes a navy report will
come out on August 3rd refuting those
claims and blaming human error okay US
officials concluded it was quote a
tragic and regrettable accident so we
shot down an airliner with 290 civilians
on board tried to tried to say the
airliner was tagging us that turned out
not to be true George is not on the
campaign trail and said quote the
Iranians shouldn't be sending an
airliner over a combat zone by combat
zone he means Iran right yeah the thing
about that sort of stuff too is that
those like I think there's definitely
something
there's once someone commits some sort
of act of that nature it's terrible it's
like a blueprint but once the US does it
it sort of sends a message that it's
actually like way more okay than a lot
of other countries 100% and we're doing
that more and more and more where we're
sort of like ya know we get to do it too
and it's just the message it sends it
turns out it all started with this guy
here all right so he said to a group of
Republicans on August 15th quote I will
never apologize to the United States I
don't care what the facts are I'm not an
apology as for America kind of guy
you're that you're in an abusive
relationship then you are married to an
alcoholic who can do no wrong
so so I put this quote up on Twitter the
day he died because [ __ ] him and a bunch
of people were like duh he didn't say
that on the day it was shot down right
dumb [ __ ] he said it during the
month-long discussion and two weeks
after the report came out saying we did
which so your point that he didn't do it
on the day it was [ __ ] stupid he did
it days after when the [ __ ] country
was discussing it so you're wrong
do better ma'am Oh No but there's just
there's this hole right wait talking
point then he didn't say that in
relation to the to the shooting down on
the plane because it didn't happen right
after the plane was shot down hey no
you're right it came out he said it
after the report came but you're wrong
you can't say something about something
two weeks after it it don't exist no
longer than yeah in his nomination
speech George tried to show how manly he
was quote watch me lift this microphone
above my mouth we can this attempts
aggressor strength stop them I will not
allow this country to be made weak again
never George also said quote Congress
overreacted and seriously weakened the
CIA in speeches and iran-contra he said
quote there is this insidious suggestion
that I was conducting an operation it's
untrue unfair and totally wrong well we
know that means it's true but the
special prosecutor was still
investigating in George Iran so he's
being investigated for committing a
massive crime trading with the enemy
like his [ __ ] dad did sure running
drugs into the country yeah yeah funding
a death [ __ ] squad yes and he's
running for president yeah okay but he
eats pork rinds and then he ran one of
the most racist election campaign ads of
all time Willie Horton was serving a
life sentence for murder in
Massachusetts of course I remember yes
of course as we know Dukakis is from
Massachusetts so they decided to link
this up with Massachusetts so Willie
Horton is serving life in prison
he's furloughed they have weekend
furloughs there you get to get a prison
comeback he this guy Willie Horton gets
out he rapes a woman Bush campaign
director Lee Atwater came up with that
idea
say Dukakis furloughed him and then show
Hortons picture now
Dukakis does not furlough people he's
[ __ ] governor he's not watching the
gate so it's this big black scary guy
right they take the most scariest
picture they can find the victim was
white so
one calls the ad races George said that
it was quote absolutely ridiculous but
even right-wing operatives like Roger
stone thought the ad crossed the line
and he told that water quote you and
George Bush will wear that to your grave
it's a racist ad you're going to regret
it
what's so great is that since George HW
Bush died
we know that Roger stone was wrong there
was no talk of the Willie Horton ad it
was God what a dreamer he was huh well
what a relationship he had all the
legacy the dynasty yeah and that fuels
guys like stone to become worse don't
know is a enormous tattoo of Richard
Nixon on his back oh I do but no you
have a pets who if Roger stones back
with Nixon's tattoo on it which is meta
on his deathbed
Atwater apologized for using the Horton
ad against Dukakis and as you said
George Bush never did write anyone the
election he was he was weighed down in
the polls
two things turned the I mean he was down
by like 15 point points in the polls
two things turn around number one Horton
and number two Dukakis got in a tank
right right and he looked it looked it
looked really bad yeah III was actually
remember I was actually a young guy and
I was actually doing campaigning for
Dukakis going house to house and
knocking on doors and when that a ad
campaign camp when that picture came out
like I'm done it's over like you could
feel it was over this is immediately
over hello hi oh yeah Dukakis
ah big Gurley a New England guy in the
tank who looked like a little Mole Man
weighing over his head
okay a little good at the little guy
did the tank and he looks like he's lost
he looks like yeah what's this what's
the blind guys name the cartoon white
guy what's his name the blind guy mr.
Magoo looks like mr. Magoo in a day I
love his policies but I don't need your
pamphlet that bad is mr. Magoo the other
guy committed crimes yeah take crime I
said I call a war picture
it is good to laugh I'll tell you I've
been sitting here a little depressed all
day and then you came by just talking
about your little tank buddy okay yeah
you know GI Mike do you want to come in
my life would get a kick out of this she
really liked it really got they no III
don't want to commit to do anything such
a little cutie pie a little steak I want
to die right now uh alrighty well it's
good to laugh anyway what about the bush
he's not away well let's pull it up
because uh cuz mother likes pictures and
I made two just think about it oh this
is gonna be so maybe nature forever
they call him tank Wiener it was it's
serious I mean come on it's but this
really is the problem with life look at
this this is so dumb this really is the
front this really is the problem so you
I mean do you not understand a little
bit why people reject the Democrats
yeah Bush did this yeah Bush literally
look at this picture yes it's the word
it's one of the war fantasy camp for
didn't see it it might be the worst
photograph from presidential campaign
history if not the top two or three I
mean it it's like he's trying to make
himself seem like a tough guy
and he looks like a [ __ ] idiot oh it
just looks so dumb I mean he honestly
looks like a little kid who got dressed
up for Halloween and is about to go
trick-or-treating with his parents and
what are you I'm a presidential hopeful
well here's a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
my little baby yeah he lost the election
so George is a so Georgia's president
and now crack arrives in the mid-80s and
in in the country and that's lucky
destroying cities nothing to do with the
CIA no by the time Georgia's presidents
is ravaging neighborhoods and for his
first address from The Oval Office
George wanted to make a big splash
George said the quote first oval office
address is a big deal so live on TV he
said the biggest domestic threat facing
the US was drugs particularly crack and
then he pulled out a bag of cocaine no
don't look cuz I can't but it's one of
those ones I can't find so he pulls out
a bag of cocaine live on the air and
it's legit a huge bag right yeah some of
the best crack you're ever gonna see
okay this crack is unbelievable it's
very smokeable crack so yeah they call
them fat rocks crack it is a lot of
crack I mean you know if there were like
some people like some crack heads just
watching this like man if we can imagine
being that lucky to be President and
have that much crack so he pulls it on
live TV and he says this is the biggest
domestic threat quote this is crack
cocaine seized a few days ago by the
Drug Enforcement agents in a park just
across the street from the White House
hey Colin angels breath and I smoked a
bunch earlier I am feeling great I've
been up for four days I can do two
push-ups with my wiry arms so this is
Lafayette Park that he's talking about
there is no drug problem in Lafayette
Park there have been zero drug
insinuating that the these drugs were
right across the street he lives it's a
lie
I know drugs have there been no drug
arrests they're quote the president want
to show it could be bought anywhere days
before the speech the White House asked
the DEA for a bust in Lafayette Park a
DEA agent and contacted
and ask the dealer to come and the
dealer responded quote where the [ __ ] is
the White House yeah when he was told
what it was he said quote
oh you mean we're Reagan lives so it's
just a big PR stunt sure three ounces of
crack twenty four hundred dollars the
kid's name is Keith Jackson he's
eighteen years old twenty four hundred
dollars at this time to an eight it's an
insane it's gonna get anybody to come
out and try and sell [ __ ] drugs so he
just sets his kid up it's it's just
[ __ ] it's entrapment and Bush used the
speech to push to more than double the
amount spent on drug war enforcement
quote more prisons more jails more
courts more prosecutors an additional
1.5 billion the largest increases jobs
program yeah Keith Jackson is convicted
not of the drug buying charges but other
stuff related to it because that was
entrapment he got 10 years the drug war
would turn out to be the you know at the
end of this speech like the crack went
missing and they were just like hey w
you seen this anywhere Sheena don't know
what you're talking about the Jaguar
which had to be obviously a horrific
race to race is failure George is the
one who put it into overdrive he's the
guy in spring of 1989 and the guy who
started the drug war on crack nine the
Berlin Wall fell the Cold War is over so
now the US is the most powerful country
on earth and George did not like his
wimp image and then there was at Noriega
situation there were 18 US bases in
Panama and due to our long history with
the Panama Canal obviously that's the
thing right so we have a lot of bases
there but the canal was scheduled to be
turned over to Panama partially in 1990
and then completely in 2000 so the u.s.
is slowly gonna lose control of Panama
starting the next year well knowing how
we handles we do we just are like hey
we're talking to bye we're talk people I
say the u.s. talks too much
yeah yeah and Noriega has stopped being
helpful with a contra stuff oh and
Noriega has all that blackmail material
right Noriega quote I've got bush by the
balls so suddenly the us tiny raisin
balls so suddenly in the US
everyone is talking about how bad of a
guy no are you good oh yes what we do
after years no problem it's just the
same [ __ ] different day
well this is what started it so it's it
he's been a CIA informant right forever
he's been making $100,000 a year since
1976 he's on the government [ __ ]
payroll but now he's upset George and
he's also you know a problem with the
Panama Canal right so the media goes
into overdrive now he's the most
frightening thing since Hitler it's it's
in a matter of months its purest by the
way if he was as bad as Hitler Bush
would have hired him for the White House
on December 20th 1989 US forces attacked
Panama City the purpose of the invasion
was simply to capture Noriega on drug
charges
okay US officials were told the exact
location of Noriega by a diplomat three
hours after the operation began okay
quote but when I called SOUTHCOM that's
the people in charge of the operation
SOUTHCOM said that had other it had
other priorities yes the total
destruction of the very poor
neighborhoods of El choryo and San
Miguelito why well why because two
reasons number one they were they backed
Noriega these two communities right
there have been at the time there were
so this is mess this is just more
spelling the message out a little more
clearly essentially at the time people
said there was weapons testing happening
there was absolutely no no body count so
the u.s. purposely made sure there was
not a body count quote they began
burning down el correo at 6:30 a.m. they
would throw a small device into a house
and it would catch on fire they burn
from one street to the next this is the
neighborhood that's not the neighborhood
and that's a cartoon cartoon
it's great you like the system here Wow
so we burnt down a neighborhood for no
reason no that's some could see that
that's where people lived that that is
just that is a what we call a slum and
it has just simply been burned down for
no reason why do people not like us
I don't know blocks were burned no one
knows how many were killed bodies were
piled in the streets and burned there
were mass graves the destruction of his
neighborhoods in Metheny Noriega they
just supported him after Noriega was
captured George said it was all worth it
quote every human life is precious and
yeah which is why we don't count them
and yet I have to answer yes it has been
worth it
well I mean that seriously is just
genetics then right I mean that's just
alive every one of them well he learned
from his father yeah
who and he was and W was taught by his
father the UN Security Council passed a
resolution condemning the invasion but
the US UK and France vetoed it many
countries saw what happened in Panama as
a incredibly dangerous precedent the
General Assembly then voted 75 to 24 a
resolution that called it quote a
flagrant violation of international law
yeah quote people burning to death and
the incinerated dwellings leaping from
buildings running a panic through the
streets cut down in crossfire crushed by
tanks human fragments everywhere
after these clear wardroom crimes and
disregard for international law
Georgia's poll numbers in the u.s. shot
to record highs not seen since
Eisenhower 76% Georgia shown that
American presidents would receive their
high support for illegally invading
countries and slaughtering people right
in a tank for the photo-op
bad use tanks to destroy others good yes
so this is a pretty good like this isn't
the press this is us right right this is
the people of America being [ __ ]
monsters because not just I mean it's
just insane yet that should be allowed
and that's that's your highest rating
for just so they so he caught Noriega
right so now Noriega is in jail but so
many
people died that didn't need to die by
the way he's in jail for we're all with
us I mean I don't think I have it but
there's there's a famous shot of him is
he still alive
no I think he died do I look that up
Aaron are you allowed to do that or oh
here he is I think he died recently but
I might be wrong yeah there's the famous
shot yeah so then it was all worth it so
then he's on the front of Newsweek doing
him a mug shot enemy number one and
everyone's like look at us and remember
it's wimpy George when George went and
got that don't we kill humans 2017 yeah
so he just dies Jean rest in peace you
were great inflate him the new york
times after the invasion quote for
president bush a man still portrayed in
doonesbury comic strip as the invisible
president showing his steel had
particular significance so I mean really
it's just how many people does a man
have to kill to undo a cartoon pretty
much right and yet the media continued
to attack his manhood at one point
jumping all over him for asking for
another quote splash of coffee but at
this point they're just leaping on it's
like Z before TMZ and he's we already
know he's mad about it he said he he
said he is a Republican operative
operative said he should tour the
country so he saw how real people acted
George will a Republican said his
administration suffered from quote moral
flaccidity but that's just I mean I'm
not even fully sure what it means but
you are just like I know what you're
saying if you just put flaccid in here
you know what you're [ __ ] doing
hey you limp dick [ __ ] how's it
going yeah sloppy attitude a year and a
half after the Newsweek article George
was still mad about it and he told
reporters quote you're talking to the
wimp you're talking to the guy that had
a cover of a national magazine that I'll
never forgive put that label on me
are you like a junior in high school
you're the president in the summer of
1990 Iraq and Kuwait were feuding one
issue was their borders in other words
that Iraq accused Quaid of slant
drilling and stealing their oil and the
third issue was Kuwait was over
producing oil to drive down the price of
oil so in July Georgia's US ambassador
was visited three ghosts by Saddam
Hussein representative quote was the
ambassador US ambassador quote we have
no opinion on the arab arab conflicts
like your border disagreement with
kuwait what a simple time now saddam is
threatening to invade and then that was
the George Bush administration's
response which is a green light to
invade yeah right yes Iraq invaded
Kuwait a couple weeks later George told
the American public that Iraq had
invaded Kuwait quote without provocation
or warning when pain when they defend
Saddam Hussein but if you are him you're
like wait what no you can't defense and
I was saying the sentence because if the
US had said no we will [ __ ] destroy
you he wouldn't have invaded okay okay
everybody calm down we gave him the
green light right there was provocation
and warning this would be true wait so
the Pentagon using top-secret satellite
images now said 250,000 Iraqi troops and
1,500 tanks were on the border of salt
Saudi Arabia Arabia and Iraq was
threatening to invade Saudi Arabia right
George said troops you know then America
is like go protect our boys we all love
Saudi Arabia gordon's fishermen the
president you know let's say George sent
troops to protect Saudi Arabia but
reporter gene Heller of the st.
Petersburg Times got her hands on
commercial satellite images of the Saudi
border there were no Iraqi troops it was
an empty desert Heller quote that Iraqi
build-up was the whole justification for
Bush sending troops in there and it just
didn't exist so George Bush lied which
turns out to be a family pattern George
Bush lied about
and that's how he got troops in there he
lied about why Iraq invaded he lied
about everything
had it ever fully been lied about this
much no and probably but no but no he
also lied about Pam there I can I'll do
the panel and that's a separate dollop
but everything that has happened since
9/11 the wars Isis Iraq is all because
George Bush lied 100 percent about Saudi
Arabia and Kuwait and Iraq and and
that's this is the number one
justification for bin Laden attacking
and doing 9/11 is because we had troops
in Saudi Arabia that's how what he uses
a recruiting tool for al-qaeda
so the Gulf War went swimmingly as long
as you're a US troop George dropped 800
sorry 88,000 500 tons of bombs tons of
bombs yeah and Iraq and Kuwait there are
tons of civilian casualties one
airstrike hit an air-raid shelter in
Baghdad and killed at least four hundred
eight civilians Human Rights Watch said
the Pentagon knew it had been used as a
civil defense shelter during the
iran-iraq war but we still bombed it we
bombed it on purpose the Human Rights
Watch concluded this was quote a serious
violation of the laws of war UN
resolutions under which the war were
organized did not go beyond the
liberation of Kuwait but as Iraqi troops
fled Quade back to Iraq pilots began to
bomb them on the highway air raids
pinned down the convoy then the vehicles
were attacked it was simply a slaughter
of soldiers withdrawing and then the
word started getting out about this
horrible situation on the on the highway
in which men were getting oops that's
the wrong one I blame you Erin I'm gonna
look it up here and then I got to do it
there so they're just there they
basically just got these people pinned
in and they're just blasting them in
there
in their vehicles oh wow oh my god it's
basically just a slaughter Annie both
withdrawing right and and and and words
getting out that they're that they are
withdrawing and so the US Central
Command starts getting freaked out that
that word is getting out that there was
drawing and we're killing people
withdrawing because you're not supposed
to do that right and then Sonam
announced the troops who were drawing
and that that had started before the
u.s. started bombing and the Pentagon
decided to use quote forceful language
to portray Iraq's claimed withdrawal as
a fighting retreat due to us attack so
the forces are retreating if the bombing
started the forces are retreating that's
different than if they start pulling out
before the attacks right okay way
they're not giving up it's a legal
justification in war crimes basically
the next day George Bush made a hasty
televised a statement saying the war
would continue despite Saddam's
withdrawal announcement we found a bunch
of crack on him back this size he said
Iraq could not be trusted Iraqi troops
were retreating under pressure not
voluntarily withdrawing and that Saddam
was trying to get a political victory
from a military route he said Saddam
would not get a propaganda victory which
America [ __ ] loves that's just right
so the bombing continues it became known
as the highway of death as hundreds of
Iraqi soldiers were killed in their
vehicles she's major Bob Nugent army
intelligence officer quote even in
Vietnam I didn't see anything like this
it's pathetic
a pilot quote it was like shooting fish
in a barrel but everything in the US
military and the bush said about it was
a lie Washington Post quote in fact
however tens of thousands of Iraqi
soldiers in and around Kuwait City had
begun to pull away more than 36 hours
before Allied forces reached a capital
so we just literally just killed them
and the rationale for doing that is just
to be like we're winning by this much oh
no what is that that's a burnt guy no
that's what should be on the news like
yeah you want to kill people in war then
put that [ __ ] on the news let's see the
bodies
[ __ ] when the war ended the highway of
death became a tourist attraction
Kawai tease with video cameras walked up
and down the highway to record the
devastation coalition soldiers toured
the mayhem taking pictures of each other
besides junk tanks armored personnel
carriers and vehicles and bodies during
the war u.s. bomb was purposely
destroyed civilian infrastructure like
electrical plants water treatment plants
food processing plants Washington Post
quote some target targets especially
late in the war we're bombed primarily
to create post-war leverage over Iraq
not to influence the course of the
conflict itself so yeah I mean at that
point that really is when you're like if
you haven't lost the people already you
are like this is a very clear
distinction of now you not only are we
gonna leverage your government we're now
gonna leverage you completely well
they're just trying to well if you if
you blow up water treatment facilities
sewer and electrical your pendant you're
killing children yeah like you're you're
now purposely trying to kill other lis
children and people who you know have
the hardest time a Harvard public health
team concluded four months after the war
that the destruction of the Iraqi
infrastructure resulted in acute
malnutrition and epidemic levels of
cholera and typhoid which is why it's
it's humans rights violation to target
infrastructure like water treatment
which is why it's a yeah it's a human
violation by January 1992 a demographer
with the US Census Bureau estimated the
word caused the deaths of a hundred
fifty eight thousand Iraqis thirteen
thousand immediate civilian deaths and
then 70,000 for damage done to
electricity and sewage treatment plants
and then the Bush administration
threatened her with termination I just
it would be nice if there like the
numbers weren't fudged like everything
else is [ __ ] it would be nice if you
just at least because that's the same
thing that happened in Iraq the last
time it happens in Afghanistan where
you're like we I think we think we
killed about 3000 people it's like no
300,000 I can't I came home exactly what
it was but during the the last
Iraq war when the occupation was going
so bad they changed the definition of
killing someone in combat right so if
someone was like an AED is in combat no
no no Iraqis if an Iraqi shot at you
that or pointed a gun that's killing in
combat but if you shot it if he shot him
in the side or the back that's not an
official killing combat right so George
yeah
George also encouraged Iraqis to rise up
against Saddam and the north where the
Kurds were there was a no-fly zone but
in the South Iraqis took this as a sign
they would have protected by the US if
they rebelled so they did as George Bush
had encouraged them and then they were
slaughtered as the u.s. sat by and
watched and Iraq George HW Bush's
feel-good story remember when the press
was acting how awesome he was after he
died yeah I do I do and I know it's
funny because I remember thinking I
don't think he was that good and now I
know
and Iraq George Bush is like the Royal
Wedding the human and in Iraq George HW
Bush is seen as a criminal he imposed
brutal sanctions in 1990 the harshest in
un history salaries in Iraq fell by up
to 90% Jesus children and elderly
suffered the most
an elderly Iraqi quote we only remember
him for death pain sadness starvation
the destruction of Memphis
infrastructure Iraqis under siege ate
dirt because of Bush the sanctions
remained in place until his son invaded
Iraq in the summer of 1991 July 19 1st
1991 President Bush nominated Clarence
Thomas to fill the Supreme Court seat
left vacant by Thurgood Marshall the
first black Supreme Court justice
Thompson had been a judge for only 16
months near the end of Thomas's hearings
he was accused of sexually harassing
Anita Hill who had worked for him she
testified and was brutally attacked by
the right while some of the Democrats
stood silent two other women were
prepared to testify and we're waiting in
the back room of the Senate but Joe
Biden did not call them as the sexual
harassment claims unfolded George said
quote I have total confidence in Thomas
George chose to say
the man who multiple women described
harassing them he sent a message to
America that women should not be
believed in April 1990 which is which
ended thankfully that's right we wrapped
that yeah like yeah at any hearing yeah
be honest we will listen to you isn't it
great how much different Trump is yeah
in April 1992 at a campaign fund like
beer did George HW Bush make Clarence
Thomas take a vow of silence after that
he never says a word because he's a
[ __ ] idiot
yeah [ __ ] 16 months in court he's like
people people are saying that that that
Trump is putting guys on all over the
place that aren't so did he oh yeah I
mean Jesus Christ in April 1992 had a
campaign fundraiser in Michigan a woman
posed with George for a photo he she
said he groped her ass quote it was like
a gentle squeeze
Thomas was Oh Thomas was confirmed with
eleven Democrats voting for him you're
the problem Democrats that's right
and January 19 1992 at a banquet Japan
Jorge leaned over and vomited in the lap
of the Japanese Prime Minister by the
way also when he did that he looked as
wimpy as papa
he couldn't it looked like you put
grandma in like the Blue Angel yeah
during his presidency George also
solidified further Republican ties with
evangelicals to do this people had to
die a lot of really good meaningful
stuff he bowed to their anti LGBTQ
agenda as the AIDS epidemic blew up when
he took office he said he would do more
to battle AIDS but that was just talk
his administration dragged its feet on
drug treatment and would not address
prevention in the gay community which
could have been done by promoting and
funding safe safe sex programs and
condom distribution act up eventually
targeted him at his main summer retreat
see now people are like you don't yell
at them in in restaurants and stuff
act-up went to his [ __ ] house yeah
George responded by sighs I love that
like don't come on don't ruin their meal
it's like everything yeah
I can't shout it like I can't shout at
them when they're getting there what the
[ __ ] are you talking about if every
right if I saw Sarah Huckabee Sanders oh
no they shouldn't be allowed to go out
in public I can yell yeah and there's
Democrats too I mean gladly Democrat a
vogue odd Dave we need this we DC for a
week yeah we do
George responded by saying quote
behavioral change is the best way to
fight the disease that's right time
machines and behavioral change now
remember how good of a guy he is right
yeah during a televised interview George
has asked what he would do if he had a
gay grandchild okay he said he would
love the child but wouldn't tell the
child he was normal that's how you love
something
George's cabinet was full of anti-gay
zealots his health secretary teamed up
with a evangelical leaders to cover up a
government study that found that LGBTQ
teens were at higher risk of suicide he
publicly denounced same-sex marriage in
Christmas Christmas Eve 1992 defense
secretary Caspar Weinberger was about to
go on trial for perjury and obstruction
of justice for the iran-contra
investigation so it's six it's six years
later it's finally [ __ ] time about to
happen George Bush about to go pardoned
him what
imagine if there was a president that
was involved in a crime and it was a
blatant crime and they were about to put
on trial and take down his
co-conspirators and he pardoned them
imagine imagine what would happen people
would be it up in arms right they would
tear down the government wall I feel
like you're making a connection Walsh
the prosecutor quote the Weinberg pardon
marked the first time a president ever
pardoned someone in whose trial he might
have been called as a witness because
the president was knowledgeable of the
factual events underlying the case Walsh
was furious he accused George of
misconduct and helping to complete the
iran-contra cover-up there were notes
that Weinberger taken which said Bush
was involved in planning
he'd been in meetings about secret
funding by pardoning Weinberger Bush
prevented a trial in which evidence of
his own involvement in the breaking of
the law would have come out the New York
Times quote in a single stroke mr. Bush
swept away one conviction three guilty
pleas and two pending cases decapitating
all that was left of mr. Walsh's efforts
which began in 1986 he pardoned Elliott
Abrams former Assistant Secretary of
State Robert McFarlane former national
security adviser and former CIA
officials Claire George Allen Friars and
Duane Clarridge
so whatever people are saying Trump is
gonna do to get out of [ __ ] and nothing
will [ __ ] compare to what this
[ __ ] did nothing because this
guy slaughtered people in Nicaragua for
[ __ ] years for years illegally
somewhat so that Congress passed two
amendments to make him stop and he still
[ __ ] did it
and he and he gets away it shows it
shows you that people's expectation of
about Trump and what is about to happen
with Trump the perspective needs to
shift because if you think that there's
going to be the Captain America rides in
and takes trump away in handcuffs
absolutely not no that's not what
happens it's not a disease
there's a domino that's gonna fall and
then Trump's going to you know get in
the way of it in some capacity and it's
gonna be on the reaction of the people
to demand what happens now and they will
do nothing they'll go out on the protest
because that's all they want to do is
protest and protest ain't gonna cut it
it's not gonna come out in his final
report on the Iran Contra affair ax in
August 1993 Walsh said quote the
criminal investigation of Bush was
regrettably incomplete he angrily said
the iran-contra cover-up which has
continued from within six year six years
has now been completed
in November 2003 Rosalynn Corrigan was a
16 year old girl whose father was a CIA
officer she met George Bush at a meeting
of CIA officers in Texas they took a
picture together and as they posed he
reached out and groped her ass
quote my initial reaction was absolute
horror I was really confused I was a
child on August 2016 an actress was
doing a play near Kennebunkport Maine I
think that's where that's his summer
home that is his summer home okay so
there's a sixteen-year-old girl someday
she's this actress is doing a play near
Kennebunkport Maine George was known to
go to the theater and he came backstage
during intermission all the actors
gathered for a photo with him the
actress said other actors warned her
that George had a reputation for
fondling women during photo ops closest
I guess I was thinking he's in a
wheelchair what harm could he do well he
reached down to her ass as the photo was
taken and said quote do you want to know
who my favorite magician is David
Copperfield and then he grabbed her
Barbara was there too and she said quote
he's gonna get himself put into jail and
everyone laughed in 2008 like a war
criminal can be threatened with jail
when it comes to a scrapping and 2018
another actress said Bush quote touched
me from behind from his wheelchair with
his wife Barbara Bush by his side he
told me a dirty joke and then all by
being photographed he touched me again
Jesus that ass groping led many of the
other other women to come out altogether
was eight women Bush's spokesman do not
tonight but said the bush was innocent
quote he has padded women's rears in
what he attended to be good natured
manner
well guess what [ __ ] yeah all the
women that haven't you didn't feel this
yeah george w bush died and that's fine
I was arrested protesting both the
Panama evasion and the first Gulf War I
should put that out there that I'm not a
fan so every single thing that George HW
Bush did set up what Trump is doing and
what everyone's upset about that's the
reality of the situation you can you can
scream about everything Trump was doing
but we already had a president get away
with a crime by pardoning people and the
Congress did not change the rules so why
would you [ __ ] think anything
differently and also if you don't know
your history
[ __ ] off like you're [ __ ] acting like
Trump is a new goddamn thing no this has
happened before
read a [ __ ] book it was it was
[ __ ] twenty years ago every record
spoken it was [ __ ] thirty years ago
just I mean [ __ ] man it's it's the same
[ __ ] just watching him [ __ ] scam but
he it's gonna be a [ __ ] Constitution
crate already was a constitutional
crisis it already happened yeah and the
way you get through it is by ignoring it
no the way you get through it is to make
him a hero when he dies [ __ ] now he's
a hero he's a [ __ ] criminal should
have died in prison for slaughtering
Nicaraguans he should have died in
prison and and all of these [ __ ] I'm
gonna say Democrats because of course
Republicans all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
Democrats acting like he's awesome guy
he was a [ __ ] evil [ __ ] yeah
an evil man from top to bottom and he
should have been in jail for war crimes
and for what the [ __ ] he did ignoring
Congress and doing his own goddamn
operation black eagle [ __ ] him we want
to thank mattress
I think the other thing is that when you
you just have to remember the stuff that
we have done in other countries and
remember that that there potentially
will be a time when the tables of turn
and who's gonna listen to the cries from
this country [ __ ] the rest of the
world is waiting for us to fall yeah I
mean they're gonna be so [ __ ] over
right now we're like the Jenga tower
that just got the shakiest piece removed
and we're still standing somehow like it
ain't good it's not good but also the
Russia thing is a classic example of
we've done that to every country in the
world yeah really
right everyone's mad about Russia I mean
Jesus Christ clean up your own [ __ ]
side of the street first we've done that
to everybody including Russia we did it
to rush already like we do and also yeah
whatever but that's like literally our
job like it's what we do is [ __ ] up
other countries and week happens to us
wants an emirate throws a five-bedroom
yeah you don't get to play ball like
that if you punch someone in the face
and they punch you in the face guess
what you deserved it yeah whatever well
thanks for being on mum it was very nice
it wasn't it wasn't the best one for you
to be on did you like all the dead guy
in the burn guy in the car was your
favorite I think the the fisherman one
yeah I do yeah
well we tried well this is the first
redevelop yeah as a first read dollar I
guess it's true what they say I don't
remember any later